last question today is from will will
wants to know is political correctness
the same as being a social justice
warrior or SJW oh boy this this question
is going to open up a lot of critiques
and comments and insults I am sure from
the Internet community no political
correctness and social justice warrior
are not the same thing social justice
warrior is a generally meant negatively
title assigned to individuals that are
seen or self proclaimed that they're
fighting for what they view is social
justice and the critique is that the
social justice warriors are either
concerned with the wrong issues or using
bad tactics or concerned with things
they shouldn't be concerned about and
you often hear all of these other
catchphrases used like virtue signaling
and concern trolling etc etc so social
justice warrior is something that many
people consider themselves to be as a
positive thing and a term that has taken
on decidedly negative connotations in
some communities including some right
wing internet communities so that that's
one thing political correctness is a
term that is used mostly as a critique
of those who believe that to sort of be
charitable in terms of what they believe
that words have meaning that it makes
sense to choose words carefully and that
it makes sense not to as I like to say
be offensive for the sake of being
offensive now I am someone who has
spoken out against what I consider
irrational or overbearing political
correctness to the extent that it exists
at the same time I believe that just
walking around and and constantly
slamming overbearing political
correctness as many in the right and
many in our in our online audience do is
sort of a distraction and as producer
Pat put it really well to a caller who
some weeks ago said that he had voted
for
Donald Trump because he was against
political correctness and we changed his
opinion about who he should have voted
for within about four minutes Pat asked
a really good question which is what
phrase or term do you want to use that
you feel you can't because of political
correctness and I think that is a really
great question to be asking those who
criticize supposed overbearing political
correctness so one example that I think
is an example that we should be sort of
concerned with is we can't say according
to some the phrase radical Islam I have
no problem using that term and we've
talked about radical and extreme
Christianity we've talked about radical
and extreme elements of many religions
and cults etc and that is something that
exists and I think that it is no problem
to say that I've made that very clear on
the other hand to say that overbearing
political correctness has unfairly made
it not okay to use terms like [ __ ] or
the n-word or the K word for Jews or
whatever I find that to be a completely
flaccid and bogus critique because those
are words that by and large when they're
used they're used either out of total
ignorance as to the impact and
historical significance that many of
those words have or they're being used
deliberately to insult people so when
people say hey I don't like overbearing
political correctness
well what word or phrase is it that
you'd like to be parroting spouting off
about that you feel you can't and if you
get a list or maybe even just one and
then we can try to figure out well why
is it that you're so desperate to use
that word that you're making political
correctness an issue for making it not
okay socially for you to use that word
and let's explore what that means about
you so PC and social justice warrior
totally different things my views on
those issues totally different and
my senses that there will be many many
reactions to this from people in our
audience we have a great bonus show
today I don't even have time to tell you
what is on it but believe me just trust
me it's a tremendously good bonus show
and you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership if normal membership
prices are too high for you by all means
use the coupon code
I voted 17 all one word all lowercase
I voted 17 and you'll get a nice
membership discount that hopefully will
make it more affordable and we just want
people involved at any price level if
you can't pay the full price I'm glad to
offer discounts because we're building a
movement here and Buy in at any
financial level is really really
important and appreciate it I'll speak
to you on the bonus show in just a few
minutes